I was born in Alabama yeah they're in
rookerville yeah we were talking about
oh Michael Rooker your old buddy from
Tombstone I'm trying to get in touch
with him because I want you to tell a
Rooker story because on the podcast he's
you were listening to it yes Rooker says
um no no I don't get angry if I get
angry I get angry like I'm acting angry
I'm acting angry and then you started
laughing because you were listening to
that and you said that's [__] ask
him about come on well I I don't know
about any I don't know
about other times but I know but he's an
intense guy is it funny but intense you
know dude when he was on Tombstone and
when he blew up George cosmatos uh and
he got in Jersey cosmato's face um I
don't think that was for effect I don't
you know what happened
at George cost models was an idiot I I
basically uh George cosmodels replaced
another director Kevin jar on that movie
right and George cosmatos uh just was
uh brought in
um and nobody really liked him this is
the truth I met him
I said I said five words to him the
entire time I made that movie and he was
he was the director on he got credited
for directing that movie
all right I met him I said hello
and he started talking it was you know
around a couple of other people I just
said hello
and uh and then the next day I watched
him directing the way he treated people
uh and um the next time he approached me
um I he said Michael and I said go [__]
yourself
and that was the only
five words I ever said to George cost
models go [__] yourself go [__] yourself
based on just what you're my
observations of the way that he treated
people on that set you know he would say
things like yeah tell the uh extra with
the big tits to to take two steps
forward you know and whoa he was a guy
that
if you were above him on on the food
chain he'd kiss your ass so he he he
tried to kiss my ass but if you were
below him on the food chain he'd treat
like [__] what about that he found
kilmery treated him with respect
um Sam Elliott uh Billy Bob no all those
people they like him nobody liked him
nobody liked him well he didn't really
he didn't really direct the movie Nobody
directed it you know uh people say uh
did did Kurt Russell uh direct the movie
and the fact of the matter is it's a
little bit like a football team Michael
you have a coach that goes down so the
coach is gone they like the former coach
what say that the director from before
that got fired or no that's that's a
whole another conversation I liked him
right I liked him a lot uh and um I
think he's more responsible he wrote the
script and uh he's a great writer he
wrote glory and uh he's a great writer
but he was very rigid and he didn't
understand how collaborative uh
filmmaking was especially those creative
actors well I know he had Kurt Russell
who's been a movie star since he was
like five
um he had Val Sam me Powers Booth Powers
Booth and I had a great time yeah that's
intimidating by the way well but it's
not Tim I mean that coming in as a
director you have to kind of have that
maybe that's what this new director was
like I'll just be a [__] badass and
people treat people like [__] because he
was insecure nah he was just he was just
an [__] yeah he was just an [__]
and uh uh but that you know that movie
uh came out uh
uh you know they they waited four weeks
into the shooting of that movie to
um fire Uh Kevin jar
so you see if you get a director there's
problems you know there's arguments or
creative differences you know a weekend
or whatever we had three months to shoot
that movie and four weeks in they fired
Kevin John they used none of the footage
that he uh
uh that he shot so there's a lot of
Tombstone that got cut out before we
even shot it there was so much uh with
the Cowboys with me and Powers uh that
got cut out of the movie uh and and uh
all the girls all the women in the movie
all their stuff got cut out all the
wives uh the Love Story which was you
know that was a big part of the movie
that got cut on set when this new
director just pops up and are you guys
this movie's not going to go anywhere
this is going to be a piece of [__]
here's the thing here's the thing about
it uh Michael for me
um I can only really concentrate on on
the character that I'm playing and I
don't really have I don't have any
control over what happens and
um uh I don't really give a [__] about
morale I've you know I'm there I'm gonna
be good and and and that was a really
great character